bonjour
après avoir parlé d'eux
mieux la liaison me semblait tout trouvé
pour vous reparler d'un auteur qu'on a
déjà eu l'occasion d'aborder plusieurs
fois sur cette chaîne un auteur qui
revient en force à notre époque à savoir
nietzsche
et quand on parle de nietzsche il y un
concept qui revient assez régulièrement
un concept souvent mal compris mais
qu'on ne peut pas ne pas connaître
si on veut véritablement comprendre
l'essence de la philosophie
nietzschéenne
concept c'est le nihilisme
pour comprendre ce que signifie le
concept de nihilisme chez nietzsche
la pierre d erreur serait de regarder la
définition de ce mot dans le
dictionnaire
parce que le sens courant du mot
nihilisme risque fort de créer un
contresens par rapport au sens dans
lequel l'emploi nietzsche
et si nous ne comprenons pas le mot nous
ne comprendrons pas la réalité derrière
le mot
si nous comprenons pas le sens du mot
nihilisme dans l'oeuvre de nietzsche on
passe à côté du noyau dur de sa critique
de la critique qu'il adresse au monde
moderne
et alors sa réponse au monde moderne ne
pourra pas être comprise et entendu
alors qu reproche exactement nietzsche
au monde moderne
il faudrait plutôt dire au monde moderne
européen
c'est d'être l'héritier de valeur
mortifère
ces cinq reproche nietzsche à l'occident
moderne et même à l'occident depuis
socrate
être porteur de valeurs mortifère
évidemment la question c'est que
recouvre l'adjectif mortifère
quoi renvoie-t-il dans l'esprit de
nietzsche
et là vous pourriez croire que lorsqu'il
parle de valeurs mortifère nietzsche
fait référence à des choses telles que
la guerre ou la destruction de la nature
et la biodiversité
harari rappelé dans son livre qu'homo
sapiens avait toujours été un serial
killer écologique
l'homme est un être destructeur un être
qui se complaît dans la violence et
d'une certaine manière il n'est pas
injustifiée de considérer que l'occident
a été historiquement un agent de mort et
de destruction sur terre
est ce que c'est ça dont parle le
nietzsche
non
ou pas
ça n'a rien à voir avec ça
on pourrait même dire que c'est
exactement le contraire
leur mortifère selon nietzsche ce sont
les valeurs par lesquelles nous
exprimons notre rejet de la force vitale
et la force vitale qu'est ce que c'est
c'est l'énergie qui anime toute chose
vivante
et qui à pouce à persévérer dans son
existence
les plus habitués d'entre vous auront
sans doute fini par s'apercevoir de ce
fil conducteur conceptuel qu'on retrouve
chez plusieurs auteurs à savoir l'idée
que tout ce qui existe est animé par une
force
chez schopenhauer cette force appelle la
volonté
chez spinoza c'est le conatus
chez freud de la pulsion
et chez nietzsche cette force
gravitationnelle qui régit le monde et
les interactions au sein du monde sait
ce qu'il appelle la volonté de puissance
bien si vous comprenez ce qu'est la
volonté de puissance
vous comprendrez du même coup ce qu'est
le nihilisme
car le nihilisme
c'est le rejet de la valeur de la
volonté de puissance
août et je vais avoir beaucoup de choses
à vous dire pour expliciter tout ça
et pour sam je vais commencer par vous
demander de vous représenter un tableau
de l'antiquité
qu'est ce qu'on trouve sur ce tableau
trouve par exemple des dieux et des demi
dieux
on trouve the avec sa cinquantaine de
maîtresses
ceusses qui occupait son temps à faire
la guerre à son père
on retrouve également prométhée prom
était condamné à se faire dévorer fois
chaque jour par un aigle
parce qu'il avait volé le feu sacré
odieux
sur ce tableau de l'antiquité on trouve
aussi les androgynes
ces créatures à la fois mâle et femelle
coupée en deux pour avoir défié les
dieux est condamné à rechercher leur
moitié manquante toute leur vie
et du côté des mortels on trouve des
héros tragique
dayraut trajet qui subissent la volonté
des dieux qui se déchirent entre devoir
moral et passion amoureuse qui se
suicident désespoir parce que la
pression des passions est trop forte en
eux
cette fresque que je viens de vous
décrire
c'est la fresque de la vie
c'est la fresque de la force vitale qui
s'exprime au travers de nous et qui en
fin de compte des cris notre condition
la vie se
pas le repos
10 c'est le mouvement c'est par
définition le mouvement
dire que cette fresque est la fresque de
la vie ce n'est pas adopté une position
de légitimation
ce n'est pas d'hier c'est bien ou c'est
mal
c'est dire c'est comme ça
c'est la vie qui est conçu ainsi
qu'on le veuille ou non
et le nier ne changera pas le fait que
c'est comme ça
fresque de la vie cette fresque de la
volonté de puissance
nietzsche veut la célébrer
il veut célébrer la vie sous toutes ses
formes
la vie dans le spectre infinie de ces
variations
la vie qui fait qu'on rit ou qu'on
pleure qu'on aime ou qu'on aime
vous qu'on assassine
bref la vie dans tout
f
la vie
fait les reliefs parce qu'elle est
profusion d'énergie à travers la matière
comme une terre montagneuse qui
témoignent des secousses sismiques
et si j'ai choisi d'illustrer sa part un
tableau de l'antiquité mythologiques et
tragique
c'est parce que c'est ça la vie selon
nietzsche
un torrent de force qui se déchaînent
un concert de vitalité qui ne laisse
jamais le monde en repos
pour le repos n'est pas le but de
l'existence selon nietzsche
existence il n'y en a qu'un
c'est de vivre
ces dons bras c'est la vie
serré jusqu'à l'asphyxié
et la glorifier jusqu'à épuisement la
lumière
la tragédie antique vient du fait que la
tragédie était une synthèse esthétique
de la condition humaine
une condition humaine marqué par la
lutte entre les passions et la raison et
le triomphe des forces si rationnelle la
tragédie
c'est l'union du johnny diack et de la
polignan
c'est l'union
l'ivresse et de la mesure
font de la vie et dionysiaque
font de la vie et forcé non sens
et apollon le raisonnable l'organisateur
vient introduire du sens dans ce qui
fondamentalement n'en a pas
la liste ce
on des adorateurs d'apollon
lui et du côté de
je disais
et parce que la vie n'a pas d'autre sens
ni d'autres buts qu elle même parce
qu'il est vain de croire dans des
abstractions métaphysique qui ne font
que détourner nos yeux de son absurdité
radical il faut s'empresser de vivre
vivre intensément
vivre comme si on voulait que notre vie
se répète éternellement
on imagine bien
que la santé fragile de nietzsche et pu
l'amener à une sorte de fascination pour
la vie
c'est d'ailleurs le premier à dire que
notre philosophie est d'abord le produit
de notre corps
c'est la physiologie qui détermine la
psychologie
c'est l'avis du cor l'avis des
profondeurs qui modélise la vie des
idées
et c'est cette cyber sensibilité à la
vitalité cet enthousiasme pour la vie
que nietzsche voit partout condamné
depuis des milliers d'années
nietzsche a l'impression que cette
exaltation de la vie l'histoire la
rejette
les hommes la rejette
rejettent ils il la rejette parce que
notre civilisation leur a appris à la
rejeter
parce que l'exaltation de la vie a été
battue en brèche par tous les systèmes
de valeurs dominant depuis l'antiquité
et qu'ont en commun tous ces systèmes de
valeurs
ils ont en commun
restructuré autour de l'idée du bien
jce du bien dictée par dieu qu'il
s'agisse du bien de socrate et platon du
bien moral ou du bien politique
tous les systèmes de valeurs ont en
commun de tendre vers une idée du bien
si les définitions du bien sont
multiples et parfois contradictoires
entre elles le fait est que cette
référence aux biens a toujours été une
constante des sociétés humaines
sauf que là un problème se pose
un problème de taille
parce que qui décrète ce qu'est le bien
quelle instance détient l'autorité pour
définir ce qu'est le bien est ce qu est
le mal
c'est ça la question que pose nietzsche
qui décide du bien
de respecter son prochain et qu'il est
mal de tuer
très bien mais pourquoi
on dit qu'il est mal de détruire qu'il
aime
avoir recours à la force
pourquoi qui fixe les limites du
légitime et du non légitime
et en posant cette question
nietzsche c'est qu'il pose la question
fatidique
nietzsche est qu il pose une question à
laquelle la réponse ne peut être qu
arbitre r
car il est évident que ce qu'on appelle
le bien on l'appelle bien par rapport à
nous
nous vivons dans la croyance selon
laquelle le bien serait quelque chose
d'absolu
quelque chose de parfaitement
indépendant du point de vue humain comme
si le bien était une sorte d'idée
flottante qui planait au dessus du monde
on retrouve ici d'ailleurs le champ
lexical platonicien
la référence au ciel des idées
des idées qui seraient des réalités
immuable qui existeraient indépendamment
de l'esprit humain
mais nietzsche dément totalement cette
croyance
pour lui les idées ne sont pas des
réalités métaphysique et transcendante
les idées ne sont pas des entités qui
flottent au dessus du monde
les idées sont des produits de notre
intérêt
c'est ça que nietzsche cherche à
affirmer
nos idées nos valeurs ne sont que la
traduction de notre intérêt
et de la même façon qu'on qualifie les
moustiques d'insectes nuisibles
parce qu'il nous dérange de la même
façon on qualifie de nuisibles et de
mauvaises l'ensemble des actions qui
portent préjudice à notre intérêt
car en tant qu êtres doués de
sensibilité
en tant qu'être capable d'éprouver de la
douleur nous définissons comme
appartenant au mal tout ce qui nous
occasionne de la douleur
à commencer par la violence
donc si nous condamnons la violence si
nous la rendons dans la catégorie du mal
ce n'est pas parce qu'il existerait au
dessus de nous un concept du mal dont la
violence serait l'une des versions
la condamnation de la violence ne vient
pas d'une entité abstraite et
métaphysique
la condamnation de la violence vient du
fait que nous la subissons
[Musique]
et nous ne voulons pas la subir
1 pour nietzsche l'origine de nos
concepts moraux la traduction sous forme
de valeurs de ce qui correspond en
réalité à notre intérêt
c'est d'ailleurs ce que disait le
fondateur de l'utilitarisme jeremy
bentham quand il disait que tous les
systèmes moreau étaient en fait des
systèmes visant à maximiser le bien-être
humain de manière indirecte
c'est parce que nous désirons le
bien-être et rouge dont la douleur que
nous adaptons nos concepts moraux à
cette aspiration du corps
que ce soit pour bentham haut pour
nietzsche les créations de l'intellect
répondent d'abord à des besoins du corps
et selon eux il est totalement hypocrite
de dire que nos conceptions morales sont
indépendantes du rapport à notre corps
il est hypocrite d'affirmer que nos
valeurs morales serait désintéressée
nos valeurs morales ne sont pas
désintéressés
elles ne sont pas le fruit d'un élan
spontané à la moralité
nous avons la morale de nos espoirs
physiologique
donc si nous rejetons la violence si
nous la rangeant dans le camp du mal
c'est parce que nous voulons
fondamentalement éviter d'y être
confronté
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'atteinte à
l'intégrité qu'elle soit physique ou
morale et qui correspond à la
formulation juridique de notre rejet
viscéral de la violence
alors certes la violence est approuvé
dans de nombreux systèmes de valeurs
mais quand elle l'est c'est en général
en tant que modalités de la sanction
on utilise la violence pour sanctionner
un crime ou un méfait
une autre manière de dire que la morale
devient ce qu'elle condamne quand il
s'agit de punir
pour revenir à la question du mal et à
la conception morale du mal nietzsche
perçoit dans la représentation moral de
la violence la marque d'un parti-pris
philosophique et ce parti-pris
philosophique pose problème à nietzsche
parce qu'il s'agit de prendre parti
contre la vie elle même
dans cette condamnation morale de la
violence nietzsche perçoit une
répression de l'essence même de la vie
on l'a vu la vie
c'est aussi de la violence
c'est aussi de la force qui s'exprime
vouloir condamner l'expression de la vie
c'est vouloir condamner la vie
et c'est ce qui fait dire à nietzsche
que la morale ne pouvait être que
l'invention des faibles
je parle ici de la morale au sens où on
l'entend
la morale issues du christianisme et de
l'humanisme
la morale qui défend le faible
déprédations du fort
ce que nietzsche appelle la morale
d'esclaves
la morale d'esclaves semblable à la
morale de l'agneau qui qualifie l'oiseau
de proie de méchant non pas parce qu'il
existerait au dessus du monde quelque
chose qui s'appellerait la méchanceté
mais tout simplement parce que l'oiseau
de proie se nourrit de l'agneau
et c'est tout simplement parce qu'il ne
veut pas être dévoré que l'agneau
invente la catégorie du méchant
parce que de son point de vue daniau le
mal
c'est l'oiseau de proie
le mal
lui qui on veut à sa vie
mais supposons un instant que l'oiseau
de proie se retrouve prisonnier d'une
tornade
est-ce que l'oiseau de proie ira dire
que la tornade et méchante
peut-être sans doute même mais s'il le
fait ce sera justement parce que à ce
moment là l'oiseau 3 aura subi la force
de la tornade
pour nietzsche nous condamnons ce que
nous
buisson
si la morale condal l'effort c'est parce
que les créateurs de la morale subissent
la force d'efforts
ici trois coups critiques portées à la
morale par nietzsche
premièrement
le fait qu'elle soit arbitraire
car la morale n'est en réalité rien
d'autre que le masque de l'intérêt
humain
en l'occurrence
de l'intérêt des faibles
on ne rejette pas la violence parce
qu'elle est condamnable on la juge
condamnable parce qu on la rejette
deuxièmement si la morale est arbitraire
elle est donc relative
et dire que la morale est relative
c'est dire qu'on a tort d'en faire un
absolu
c'est dire qu'on a tort de dresser des
arrières monde en croyant détenir les
sens du bien et du mal
car le bien et le mal ça n'existe pas en
dehors de notre esprit
un moral n'est pas quelque chose qui
existe au delà du monde physique
la morale n'est pas une réalité
transcendante elle est une création
psychique qui veut se faire passer pour
une loi transcendante
c'est donc ici un coup porté à toutes
les métaphysique du bien
et enfin troisièmement c'est le point
par lequel on a commencé
la morale est mortifère
et mortifère parce qu'elle nie l'essence
de la vie
elle ni le coeur de la vie qui est
indissociablement jouissance et
souffrance
plaisir et douleur
bien et mal
et elle préfère à la vie des valeurs et
des idéaux qui ne repose sur rien sinon
sur la volonté infantile de croire dans
l'existence d'un arrière monde
sur quoi le respect de l'autre et ils
font d éthique fondée sur la croyance
dans une idée du bien qui m'oblige à
respecter mon prochain sans autre raison
non
respect de l'autre est fondée sur la
crainte
le respect de l'autre est fondée sur la
lâcheté
sur la lâcheté de celui qui veut qu'on
respecte son intégrité et qui n'a pas
d'autre moyen de faire valoir cette
revendication que de l'inscrire dans le
marbre de la loi morale
celui qui a besoin de faire inscrire sa
volonté dans la loi morale est celui qui
sait que sa volonté ne sera pas
respectée autrement
loi morale c'est pour le faible le
bouclier anti agression
le bouclier miroir même
puisqu'on l'a vu
il ya un cas où la violence portent
l'uniforme de la légitimité
c'est celui de la sanction
qui vit par l'épée périra par l'épée on
peut entendre cette citation comme une
mise en garde contre l'escaladé de la
violence
mais on peut aussi l'entendre comme
l'avertissement d'une sanction
pour rester dans les citations ne fais
pas à autrui ce que tu ne voudrais pas
qu'il te fasse
c'est ce qu'on appelle la règle d'or
c'est un précepte de philosophie morale
qu'on retrouve dans la plupart des
traditions du monde
ne fais pas à autrui ce que tu ne
voudrais pas qu'il te fasse autrement
dit c'est parce que tu ne voudrais pas
qu'il te le fasse que tu juges que c'est
mal
voyez le problème de la formulation des
règles morales et des systèmes de
valeurs en général c'est que lorsqu on
leur trouve un fondement ce fondement
est toujours lié à la volonté d'éviter
un préjudice
on instaure la réciprocité que lorsque
l'on craint que l'autre nous inflige un
préjudice
et donc ça revient à dire que l'idée
d'une morale désintéressé serait une
contradiction dans les termes
pour nietzsche en tout cas c'est une
contradiction dans les termes et c'est
une contradiction qui rend insoluble le
problème de la valeur intrinsèque des
concepts moraux
il n'y a pas de valeur intrinsèque des
concepts moraux parce que les concepts
moraux sont le produit de la psychologie
des faibles
des faibles qui parce qu'ils veulent se
protéger des forts et on les comprend
eris en valeur absolue des principes qui
sont d'abord auto défensif
la morale est un artifice auto défensif
et non une réalité en soi
pour nietzsche
l'isthme c'est l'adhésion un système de
valeur basée sur la croyance en
l'existence d'une morale transcendante
de cet épisode qu'un piège dans lequel
ne surtout pas tomber serait de vouloir
comprendre la définition nietzschéenne
du nihilisme à partir de la définition
du dictionnaire
parce que si vous cherchez le mot
nihilisme dans un dictionnaire vous y
lirez que cela correspond à la négation
de toutes les valeurs morales et
sociales
au fait pour simplifier
de ne croire en rien
et là vous pourrez vous dire je n'y
comprends plus rien
dit que nietzsche critique le nihilisme
qu'il méprise et se moque même du
nihilisme
mais dans cette histoire c'est nietzsche
qui est nihiliste
puisque c'est nietzsche qui ni
l'autorité de valeurs morales
c'est nietzsche qui désacralise qui
dévalorise les valeurs
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
qui sont les nihilistes dans cette
affaire
t
les deux
mais pas dans le m
c'est maintenant
être bien attentif pour comprendre en
quoi il ya en réalité deux nihilisme
chez nietzsche
le premier ni l'isthme
sion des systèmes de valeurs instituée
c'est la négation
l'autorité des valeurs morales
c'est le nihilisme de nietzsche
c'est à dire la négation des principes
dits transcendant qui serait censé
gouverner nos vies à travers une grille
d'évaluation
selon qu'elles seront jugées bonnes ou
mauvaises
en d'autres termes
le premier nihilisme c'est le refus de
croire dans l'autorité des valeurs
reposant sur la croyance en un arrière
monde
donc de ce point de vue là nietzsche est
parfaitement nihiliste
faites m'en ni liste selon cette
définition puisque pour lui les valeurs
morales sont artificiels
et parce qu'elles sont artificiels elles
doivent s'effondrer pour laisser enfin
apparaître l'absurdité radical de
l'existence
pas d'autre sens qu'elle même la vie n'a
pas d'autre sens que celui du perpétuel
recommencement
que celui de l'éternel retour
et vouloir encadrer cette vie et lui
donner un sens qui émanerait d'un au
delà c'est se voiler la face devant la
réalité du non sens
nous fabriquons des idoles ou fabriquons
des valeurs et dieu d essence
platonicienne mais tous ces artifices
visant à donner un sens sont condamnés à
l'effondrement
et cet effondrement des valeurs cet
effondrement de ce que nietzsche appelle
les arrières monde les idéaux
métaphysique les espérances religieuse
nietzsche le considère nécessaire
donc à chaque fois qu'on se replie à
chaque fois qu'on se retranche dans
notre arrière monde comme les enfants se
réfugient dans leur monde imaginaire on
rejette la vie
finalement la seule chose qui est
vraiment une valeur
on rejette la force et le relief
rejette la passion et le tragique
on rejette un tragique qui nous effraie
au lieu de voir que l'effroi lui même
doit être embrassé
car tout dans la vie selon nietzsche
pour nietzsche valeur est con
on ne sont que les éléments d'un décor
métaphysique artificiel
j'écris son oeuvre il voit déjà poindre
le moment où tous ses arrières monde
vont s'effondrer
arrières monde au premier rang desquels
je
la phrase que nietzsche fait prononcer à
l'insensé dans le gai savoir
c'est là prophétise ation de
l'effondrement des valeurs auxquelles
nous allons enfin assister
si le personnage de l'insensé semble
désemparé et paniqué lorsqu'il annonce
cette funeste nouvelle
ils l'annoncent malgré tout comme une
occasion d'instaurer de nouvelles
valeurs
et
moore
reste morts
et c'est nous qui l'avons tué
comment nous
console et nous les meurtriers des
meurtriers
ce que le monde à posséder jusqu'à
présent de plus sacré de plus puissant a
perdu son sens sous notre couteau
qui nous lavera de ce sens
quel os pourrions-nous nous purifier
quelle explication quel jeu sacré
serons-nous force et d'inventer
la grandeur de cet acte n'est-elle pas
trop grande pour nous
ne sommes nous pas forcé de devenir
nous-mêmes des dieux simplement
ne fût-ce que pour paraître digne d'eux
car les arrières monde métaphysique que
l'humanité a édifié son arrivée à
épuisement
la rationalité technique a fini par
lever le voile sur l'absurdité du monde
et de l'existence
et si les valeurs issues de la foi en
dieu ne sont pas encore tout à fait
morte
elles sont malgré tout condamné à mort
comme la sève d'un arbre mort qui ne
circulerait plus jusqu aux fruits
travers cette citation dieu est mort
nietzsche fait un constat celui de la
dévitalisation de l'idée religieuse
et à travers elle
de toute la morale qui en est issu
pour nietzsche tout obéit à la loi vital
de l'accroissement et du dépérissement
bien le mal ont connu leur âge d'or
viens aujourd'hui le temps de leur
extinction
désormais orphelin du sens
l'homme moderne est en position
d'instituer de nouvelles valeurs
des valeurs qui ne seront plus mortifère
mais vivifiante
l'isthme de nietzsche
c'est la célébration de la vie
victorieuse de tous les arrières monde
toutes les valeurs artificiel
arrive aux seconds ils isme ledit
l'isthme combattue par nietzsche
qu'incarne la morale et la religion à
savoir le nihilisme de la vie
la négation de la vie et de la volonté
de puissance
des puissances ne correspond pas au
désir d'écraser l'autre ou de
l'assujettir
elle correspond à la volonté même de la
vie qui est puissante
la vie et puissance d'affirmation
elle est une puissance qui se moque des
cadres que les hommes ont inventé pour
la canaliser
et du point de vue de la volonté de
puissance
du point de vue de la vie dans son
affirmation brut
sont les moralistes qui sont les
nihilistes
la valeur suprême et la vie
et que la morale pose des barrières à
l'expression de la vie
c'est la morale qui est nihiliste
car c'est la morale
cette valeur suprême qu'est la vie
si ni
jouy d'assister à l'effondrement des
valeurs instituée
c'est parce qu'ils y voient l'occasion
historique
de remplacer les valeurs mortifère de la
morale par les valeurs vivifiante de la
volonté de puissance
il ya donc une différence de nature
entre le nihilisme passif des moralistes
qui recule devant la vie
et le nihilisme actifs de nietzsche qui
milite pour que la volonté de puissance
soit instituée comme nouvelles valeurs
c'est ce qu'on appelle la transvaluation
des valeurs et qui consiste dans le
dépassement des valeurs dualiste tels
que le bien et le mal au profit d'une
valeur unificatrice des contraires qui
est la vie elle même
si nietzsche et nihiliste sur le plan
des valeurs morales c'est parce qu'il
combat le nihilisme de ceux qui
voudraient faire taire la vie
ici qu'on n'a pas affaire à la même
espèce de nihilisme
le nihilisme d'effort est une négation
des valeurs
le nihilisme des faibles est une
négation de la vie
le nihilisme d'effort est une négation
de la forme
le nihilisme des faibles est une
négation de la force
koenig se tient du côté des négateurs de
la forme autrement dit c'est parce qu'il
conteste la valeur et l'autorité des
concept métaphysique et moraux qu'il
respecte d'autant plus la force qu
aucune forme ne saurait contraindre ou
limitées
transvaluation des valeurs c'est la
remise des valeurs à l'endroit
c'est le renversement des valeurs sur
leurs pieds
et qui peut certes passé par la
valorisation de vertus telles que
l'ardeur au combat
mais qui fondamentalement échappe à tout
enfermement dans un concept
force excède la forme
volonté puissance surpasse toutes les
vertus morales et c'est une valeur a de
la valeur c'est uniquement en tant qu
elle est investie d'une force par
laquelle se manifeste la volonté de
puissance
tiens pas sa valeur d'un idéal
fantasmatique de justice ou de bonté
valeur tient sa valeur de la puissance
d'affirmations qui l'animent
or selon nietzsche
alors institué ne sont pas animés par un
désir d'affirmation
tendu
s'ils ont de la puissance vitale
elles sont animées par le ressentiment
la morale de l'esclave
al du ressentiment à l'égard de la vie
qui s'exprime
si nietzsche combat là
elle réactive
la morale inventé en réaction à la loi
du plus fort
c'est pour promouvoir à sa place il
m'aura l'affirmative
la morale du surhomme
lui qui rejette le surhomme car le
nihiliste craint et jalouse à la fois la
force dont il n'est pas pourvu
hillis des celui qui méprise la force
parce que le mépris pour lui le seul
moyen de dissimuler sa peur du fort
et son désir de lui ressembler
et donc le nihiliste professeur à des
appels au respect
des appels à l'égalité
des appels à la justice
sa volonté de puissance est tourné vers
sa propre négation
sa propre négation en tant que force
vitale
sa volonté de puissance travail à sa
propre destruction
et c'est en cela que le nihilisme et
mortifère
le nihilisme
un résidu de volonté de puissance
entièrement dédié à son auto
anéantissement
ça le seul crime s'il devait y en avoir
un
l'anneau
ils ont de la volonté de puissance
le nihilisme c'est une punition
de vivre
la vie sur terre était une punition
selon le péché originel
la vie elle même qui doit être punie
selon le nihilisme
face à 100
je prône la déculpabilisation
il prône
le plongeon dans l'ici et maintenant
le plongeon dans la vie
parce que la vie est la seule chose qu
on est certain de posséder
c'est de cette chose là
découlent toutes les autres
donc aimons la vie même quand elle ne
nous aime pas je vous remercie
[Musique]